after three absolute action Classics
John Wick chapter 4 has a lot to live up
to critics have enjoyed it but does it
live up to fans sky high expectations
here's what they're saying so far the
John Wick franchise has been one of the
top action film series for nearly a
decade and despite his longevity fans
show little sign of tiring of it
moviegoers just can't get enough of
Keanu Reeves wearing slick suits and
engaging in intense gun food battles
with a variety of assassin opponents
thankfully for those eager to see more
Wick action it appears that the saga's
latest installment John Wick chapter 4
the liver circus yet again John Wick is
once again a man on a mission having
made an enemy of the dangerous and
mysterious high table he has elected to
team up with Lawrence Fishburne's Barry
King in an attempt to take the shadowy
organization down your little Act of
uncivil Disobedience inspired me John
I'm branching out spreading my wings of
course it won't be a clean or quick
fight the high table will throw
everything it has against our heroes
including faces from Wix pass the fourth
John Wick installment has wild critics
sitting at around 95 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes on its opening Friday but what
do fans have to say about it after three
films of fans largely agreed were
consistently solid from beginning to end
it's safe to say expectations were
pretty high once the credits rolled
people who saw the newest entry were
quick to jump on Twitter to let the
world know what they think and it seems
to Met fans high standards one wrote
John Wick 4 is everything I wanted it to
be that same fan highlighted the third
act and Donnie Yen's cane as two of the
film's strongest elements another
Twitter user claimed John Luke chapter 4
has the potential to be considered one
of the top 20 action films of all time
yet another fan who saw the movie called
it the best of the four John Wick
installments to reach the Silver Screen
so far fans have plenty of good things
to say about the film's action sequences
with one writing John Wick 4 is
Relentless fight choreography and stunt
people are just on a completely
different level others assured their
followers of the action and story ensure
that you hardly ever feel the film's
mammoth 169 minute run time in fact it
feels so pressed that one viewer was
disappointed when they checked the time
during their showing just to learn that
it was nearing the end one real-life
element of John Wick chapter 4 that fans
couldn't help but mention was the
appearance of Lance Reddick who played
Continental conscious Sharon in the
series Reddick died at the age of 60 on
March 17 2023 a mere few days before the
latest John Wick film made its way to
Cinemas he is a beautiful person really
special artist in the days following his
passing fans and colleagues alike have
come together to honor relic's life and
lasting impacts on the entertainment
World bearing in mind that this is one
of his final performances watching the
latest John Wick film has been a rather
emotional experience for many moviegoers
speaking on how Redix And Timely death
changes the entire complexion of John
Wick chapter 4 mon commented John Wick 4
hits different after Lance Radix passing
another agreed writing that relic's
presence on screen certainly pulled up
their heartstrings for those fans
wondering whether a memorial to Reddick
was added to the film after the actor's
passing wanted the user provided the
answer saying that includes the perfect
tribute so if you haven't seen the movie
yet be on the lookout for it when you do
foreign